- Boobs.
- BuzzFeed presents
- Women read Playboy for the first time
- I'm just gonna flip through.
- Oh I found one.
- 1960s & 1970s
- She's not even, like, naked.
Like, this, you can see this on like, ABC.
Well, not ABC.
- You can not!
- There's something so
nostalgic about this.
I'm trying really hard to
be offended (laughing).
- What has she got in her mouth?
Is that a flower petal?
- A petal.
- I like this one cause it's like
what a woman's body actually looks like.
- Do men read the articles?
- Have you seen any naked women?
- Oh wait.
- Oh that's a boob.
- Oh, I found a boob!
- We found a boob!
- We found a boob.
- I mean, like HBO, but
like a tame HBO show.
- 1980s
- Holy shit, look at that!
- No.
- Look at--
- The 60s was kinda like
ooohh
- Yeah, it was just like
- I'm coy.
- this sh--
- And the 80s are like bam!
- this shirt just--
- Bush was in, big bush.
- Ways big in the 80s.
- Huge, huge bush.
- Very clear lack of diversity.
- They have the young men
who are really just wanna
look at the pictures
and then there's the like,
I'm a little bit more sophisticated man,
I'm gonna read the articles now.
- This is too dirty.
- Then there's I'm old, I
have to read the articles
so that I don't come off as a pervert.
- 1990s
- She's so old.
- Playboy, like figure out your image.
What are you?
Are you a porno mag?
- I feel like--
Are you like Vanity Fair?
- If you're gonna have the bra on,
why even have it on?
- That, yes,
please, thank you.
- 2000s
- This is where it gets dicey.
- See, this is more like
what I'm expecting.
But they do have a red head.
- Really?
This is the centerfold?
- Ummm.
- This is not a real person.
- Blonde busty is not my type.
I like more traditional like
kind of, kind of hipster.
- 2015 Collector's Editions
- This collector's editions
are just all boobs.
- Oh these are definitely photoshopped.
- Yeah.
- That poor horse.
- He didn't want to be a part of this.
- This, that is, that's
a little bit weird.
Like, that looks like a crime scene thing.
- I'm so desensitized
to this right now.
- Yeah.
- No more words.
(laughing)
- And literally, like, there's,
they have no clothes on.
There's no hidin' it.
They're just like, in the water.
- That is what disturbs me.
It is like, just an ass.
- You know, I'm gonna say
this is kind of beautiful.
- And it was interesting how
quickly they went from like,
full bush to completely bare.
- I didn't even really view
these women as actual women.
It was more like objects of art.
- I found my cousin's Playboy once
and that was an awkward experience.
Like, I prefer to make
somebody have to work for it.
Like, I don't like when
it's just all out there
for everybody to see.
That isn't--
- You like to be teased.
- Exactly.